this uh means so much to me I I stopped
writing this movie about 20 times
because I thought it was impossible I
thought it wasn't going to work I
thought no one would ever make this
movie but I kept coming back to it
because I knew if someone let me make
this movie that people would hear it and
people would see it so I want to
dedicate this to all the people who
raised my voice and let me make this
movie you guys thank you so much to the
cast and crew I love you thank you so
much my wife who supported me through
this whole process my mother who taught
me to love even in the face of hate and
to everybody who went and saw this movie
everybody who who bought a ticket who
told somebody to buy a ticket thank you
I love you for shouting out at the
theater for shouting out at the screen
let's keep going Brian Roberts thank you
I love you all thank you so much good
night